ja meine damen und herren die
wirtschaftssanktionen treffen vor allem
auch oligarchen das waren mal oder sind
zum teil auch noch putins freunde aber
sie könnten dann auch zu seinen feinden
werden oligarchen das sind unternehmer
die während gorbatschows periode der
marktliberalisierung liberalisierung in
den 90er jahren ihre geschäfte begann
und dann meistens durch die ölindustrie
und eigene konzerne milliarden
erwirtschaftet haben seitdem putin an
der macht das haben sie nur eine wahl
mitmachen und teilen oder vernichtet
werden die bekanntesten sind roman
abramowitsch beispielsweise oleg
deripaska oder auch mit ralf
abramowitsch den wir hier sehen gilt als
ein wegbereiter für den machtwechsel von
ex präsident boris jelzin zu putin im
jahr 2000 der hat gerade den fc chelsea
verkauft wodurch ölgeschäft reich musste
aber seinen konzern dann an gazprom
verkaufen oder oleg deripaska ist
gründer und eigentümer von basic element
einer der größten russischen
industriegruppen war bis 2018 gründer
und miteigentümer
eines großen konzerns eines ami um
aluminium hersteller so michael koch auf
hier sehen wir abramowitsch noch mal er
beteiligte sich an unternehmen im
rohstoff und energie sektor also das
alles sind oligarchen und als sie sollen
jetzt getroffen werden um eben druck zu
machen auf wladimir putin um ihn zu
einer umkehr zu bewegen und zwar einfach
und allein weil es am ende dann ums
schnöde geld geht viele oligarchen sind
auch in deutschland und haben dort
immobilien beispielsweise am tegernsee
deshalb sprechen wir jetzt mit alexander
radwan er ist csu
bundestagsabgeordneter für den kreis bad
tölz-wolfratshausen schönen guten morgen
herr rat waren ich grüße sie herr
hat für einen miesbach am tegernsee da
haben auch einige russische oligarchen
ihr zuhause was konkret fordern sie
jetzt sollen die enteignet werden sollen
den ihre villen weggenommen werden
meine forderung ist dass die personen
die auf der sanktionsliste der
kommission der eu stehen also es gibt
auch viele personen die hier leben aus
verstand aus anderen ländern die ganz
normal ohne die nahezu stehen hier leben
aber die die da drauf stehen die müssten
mit aller konsequenz
verfolgt werden es geht jetzt hier im
tegernseer tal natürlich primär um die
immobilien um die wählen aber wir wollen
natürlich bekannte setzt die yacht fand
osmann auf aber auch die
firmenbeteiligungen überall da wo sie
kapital das wir zügig dazu kommen die
eigentum strukturen ausfindig zu machen
darauf weist jetzt auch notwendig dass
das bundeswirtschaftsministerium die
kompetenzen mit dem finanzministerium
mit dem innenministerium mit dem
justizministerium und den föderalen
strukturen aufklärt weil das ist jetzt
zeit kritisch wir müssen die
eigentumsstruktur erklären um dann auch
danach und das ist meine nächste
forderung wir nicht nur die vermögen
einfrieren sondern auch abschöpfen
können wie beim geldwäschegesetz oder
bei dem thema terrorismusbekämpfung bald
das thema enteignung ist eingängig aber
was ich ungern hätte was ich ablehnen
ist natürlich eine entsprechende
entschädigung gehen den deutschen weg
bei der erfolg deswegen ist zum beispiel
auch roman abramowitsch so nervös weil
er bis jetzt eben nicht auf der liste
stand das bild zwar großbritannien ist
nicht mehr in der eu aber das
damoklesschwert am ende ist ja dass er
während des eingefroren ist im gesamten
zeit warum nicht an sein vermögen
rankommt und die briten haben wir
bereits angekündigt dann dieses vermögen
einziehen zu wollen und den gleichen weg
müssen wir in deutschland gehen dass wir
jetzt schnell die vermögen aufklären
einfrieren und dann die gesetzes
voraussetzung schaffen analog geldwäsche
analog terrorismusbekämpfung um dieses
vermögen dann auch einzuziehen wie muss
ich mir das ganz konkret vorstellen
verrückter aus die polizei das
ordnungsamt geht zu den willen dort am
tegernsee und was weiß ich klebt da
irgendwelche bender vor die vor die
haustür wie muss ich mir das vorstellen
wie funktioniert das überhaupt ja das
ist also in der form sie es noch nicht
aber er denkt dass es eben auch eine der
ungeklärten sachen aus dem grundbuchamt
steht natürlich hier im landkreis
miesbach wird geklärt wer drin steht
aber dass china auch gar nicht die namen
drin sondern dahinter stehen schachtel
firmen die dann irgendwo auf der welt
verstreut sind wir haben auf bundesebene
die view im finanzministerium
nachgestellt für die finanz
bekämpfung also die geldwäschebekämpfung
wir haben wir müssen jetzt relativ
schnell allem maßnahmen möglichkeiten
haben nutzen die wir haben um ausfindig
zu machen wem das gehört wir haben das
bei der jacht dann wird man auch in
hamburg gemerkt das ist sehr kompliziert
ist und jetzt hier ein kompetenz
diskussion zwischen bund länder und
möglicherweise rituell
bezirksregierungen
bringt denen wertvolle zeit um ihre
sachen in sicherheit zu bringen ist das
im nachhinein wo man ja immer klüger ist
auch noch mal ein weckruf haben wieder
zu lange zugeschaut das russische
oligarchen sich hier die filetstücke
heraus kaufen konnten in london
beispielsweise ja auch wo ganze
straßenzüge russen gehören und damit
auch die marktpreise für normalbürger
extrem in die höhe getrieben wurden
also wir haben diese situation natürlich
auch jetzt hier im südlichen bayern hier
in ganz japan natürlich sehr extrem
wobei das jetzt nicht allein die
oligarchen sind und noch mal wer sich
hier regelkonform verhält wir sogar ein
teil der bei uns sein möchte die sind
willkommen uns geht es darum die zu
treffen die zur finanzierung und
stabilisierung des kriegstreiberischen
systems brücken dienen darum haben wir
die liste und die leute die auf diese
liste kommen müssen mit aller konsequenz
verfolgt und die müssten sich eben auch
darüber im klaren sein dass nicht nur
ihr vermögen eingefroren ist sondern das
ist zukünftig weg ist viele nah dran